a cave on the northeastern tibetan
plateau
blanketed in alpine meadows and flanked
by sheer cliffs
has long been a worship site for
buddhists over the past 10 years
it has become a hotbed for scientists
ever since a mandible fossil
recovered from the cave captured the
attention of a group of archaeologists
their new paper confirms that the cave
holds dna
from a group of ancient human relatives
ten years ago dna analysis of fossils
first thought to be neanderthal found in
denise of a cave in siberia
turned out to belong to a previously
unknown relative of neanderthals and
humans
scientists called them denisovans
this hominin group spread its genes into
the dna of
living humans now scattered as far as
papua new guinea and australia
denisovans might also be the source of
archaic dna in modern tibetans that aids
oxygen absorption in high altitudes
located roughly 3 200 meters above sea
level
by shia karst cave makes the likely
resting place for denisovans and the dna
they contributed to modern humans
crack detective work by archaeologists
led them to the excavation site
they followed the breadcrumbs from the
mandible fossil stored at a university
in northwest china
to the cave where a buddhist monk
reportedly stumbled upon the ancient
lower jaw in the 1980s
in 2019 a new method of analyzing
ancient proteins determined the jaw
probably belonged to a denisovan but
more dna evidence was needed to settle
the matter quickly the excavation site
proved rich
in archaeological remains including
bones from long extinct hyena and
rhinoceros species
this emboldened researchers to hunt for
definitive evidence of past
of in life trapped in the cave sediment
the researchers divvied up the cave
sediment into ten layers
from each of eight layers they extracted
100 to 250 milligram sediment samples
using molecular baits to fish from
mammalian and human mitochondrial dna
which is inherited along maternal lines
layers
2 3 4 and 7 were found to harbor dna
of ancient hominins after minimizing
contamination from modern humans
it was determined that 70 to 100 percent
of the dna
matched that of denisovans leaving the
researchers with no doubt
that denisovans inhabited the cave a
special optical dating technique
helped pinpoint the likely age of the
dna it scoured single grains of sediment
for varying exposure to light
over the course of millennia this
identified denisovan dna as old
as 100 000 years and as young as sixty
thousand
and portions of some grains hinted at
dna as
young as forty five thousand years not
long before modern humans
appeared in the region the seminal
research at by shia karst cave
bolsters evidence of widespread denise
of inhabitation
in mainland asia and the success of the
sediment sampling technique
could encourage similar investigations
at other archaeological sites
it also speeds up the race to discover
denis of in nuclear dna
and fossils at the cave doing so would
close the gap
in science's understanding of how denise
events and modern tibetans are related
expanding our knowledge of human
ancestry by reaching beyond
mitochondrial dna's
matrilineal limits it's a literal
manhunt
you